East County Today says Gary loved the
itunes touch what was the moment you
knew you would be okay when starting
your company
he's County right he's County that's a
little bone thugs reference to episode
number uh this county the moment I knew
that I was gonna make it was the the
first day I walked into my dad's liquor
store and and the reason I decided to
answer this question and trying to find
value for everybody watching other than
me bragging about that I had the bravado
from day one was the notion of not even
worrying about that moment meaning one
of the biggest things that I'm trying to
teach my I'm turning a lot today one of
the things I'm trying to teach all my
management here at vaynermedia and all
my founders in my startup investments
and my co-founders in companies that had
meeting with my co-founders at resi last
night the number one thing I keep
telling everybody is to not worry about
the things that don't matter
worrying about or trying to figure out
this is the moment when I made it is
something that I think cripples people
and I just don't even think about those
things I could answer this question two
ways which are the two right ways which
is one the moment I walk into my dad's
store because I had that confidence or
it could answer the other way that's
equally as true pulling on both sides
like a bridge which is I haven't made it
yet they both are right and the truth is
outside of this question I don't think
about it at all ever period and the
reason I'm answering the question is
because I'm trying to get as many of you
who are watching this show right now to
not worry about those things worry about
executing worrying about feeling good
about your life don't worry about making
it because making it is an outside force
the inside force of you just doing it is
what you should be focused on oh crap
wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe